depuis trois ans des visites guidées
pour non voyants sont offertes par le
musée des beaux-arts de montréal mais
cette fois ci le projet va encore plus
loin
une oeuvre d'alfred pellan a été
entièrement reproduite au moyen d'une
technique d'impression 3d
à droite c'est gris donc on sent quand
on pense que les enfants soient détruits
première étape c'est vraiment les lignes
contours on comprend les proportions des
éléments les uns par rapport aux autres
et le la disposition de chacun ensuite
on passe au deuxième prototype ou là on
ajoute un élément de plus on ajoute les
couleurs donc une texture est associé à
une couleur
oui je ris encore augure pour daniel
aubin un amateur d'art qui a perdu la
vue il ya cinq ans c'est tout il lui
permet en quelque sorte de revoir cette
oeuvre à nouveau c'est beaucoup
d'émotion quand on perd la vue nos
autres sens se mettre à contribution
pour nous faire voir davantage mieux
donc les l'ouïe l'odorat mais le toucher
prend beaucoup d'importance
donc on peut voir un pour en déterminer
les couleurs par les textures et les
relier
c'est génial par an dans nos imaginaires
ont fait naître le cinéma on fait
vraiment notre tête de l'eau dans notre
tête
mais maintenant en pouvant le toucher
mais on en a les prêts sont en plus de
participer de pouvoir être plus actives
- passé on suit bien
le mode fait pousser un projet de plus
de deux ans qui pourrait mener à
d'autres reproduction comme celle là il
ya des petits trucs que moi j'aimerais
améliorer pour la suite donc
on sait les couleurs complémentaires
c'est quelque chose donc ça aussi ça
m'intrigue parce que si on a dû mauvais
que du bleu et du rouge est ce qu on
combine les textures est-ce qu'on crée
une texture sait beaucoup de choses
auxquelles il faut penser qu'on est
vraiment une avec une iris
ce serait vraiment de pau les voir comme
une clientèle à part mais vraiment
déboires comme des visiteurs
comme tout le monde puis qu'ils puissent
être partie prenante du musée puisse
impliquer et puis venir et dire c'est
normal moi dimanche je m'en vais visiter
musées puis que personne question doit
justement parce qu'ils ont le temps est
venu pour le faire
jamas ah je vois pouvoir déterminer les
couleurs de
une pincée de ferran voix de peinture ou
à la mer où il ya déterminer des
paysages juste en touchant les couleurs
ce serait génial que ça la rue jusque là
des visites guidées sont offertes
gratuitement sur réservation les
premiers mardis et dimanches de chaque
mois
ici à londres et dan ou radio canada
montréal
[Musique]